un euro 20 c'est la somme que gagnent
les internautes s'ils regardent cinq
spots de pub chaque jour quand la
cagnotte atteint 30 euros elle arrive
par virement sur votre compte
un concept qui a fleuri au sein de cette
jeune équipe ni étudiant ni
entrepreneurs hébergés à la pépinière
d'entreprises du sanitas aucune
obligation d'achat pour l'internaute ou
seulement des pubs qui colle à son
profil eh ben c'est comme si tous les
soirs vous arrivez dans votre boîte aux
lettres et que vous avez que les
catalogues qui vous concerne eh ben
c'est un peu ça qu'on veut sur internet
vous arrivez vous avez seulement les
pubs que vous voulez qu'ils sont dans
votre intérêt avec les bons de réduction
qui sont dans votre intérêt et tout ça
parce que c'est vous qui l'avez voulu la
porte d'entrée de publicité mois un
questionnaire très poussées marque de
votre voiture votre budget alcool vos
critères pour choisir un restaurant les
habitudes le quotidien sont passés au
crible
objectif créer des communautés de
consommateurs une mine d'or pour les
annonceurs qui verse 50 centimes d'euro
par publicité publicis - n'est pas le
premier site de ce genre son originalité
son terrain de jeu à des concurrents qui
proposent des publicités sur le terrain
international pour internationale et qui
propose une rémunération
ceci dit d'un produit local il n'y a
personne pour l'instant c'est à dire que
si je dis que je suis une mère de
famille je dis que j'ai des enfants à
nourrir et je propose beaucoup je sais
pas du poisson par exemple eh bien on
peut proposer une publicité en dix ans
la poissonnerie de tels quartiers dont
qui à côté de chez moi propose une
promotion de -1% / tel qu'ils le poisson
et du coup ça m'intéresse
créé il y à un mois le site frôle les 12
mille inscriptions parmi les annonceurs
potentiels des fast food de la vente de
vêtements en ligne et des opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile et aussi quelques tpe
tourangelle comme un laveur de voiture